hey here's something that has really
shaken the foundations of the david
pakman show a user on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit has isolated a moment where
allegedly I appear to be spitting up I
mean it's very very weird and before you
play it Pat let me just fully set it up
I've been doing some of these live
streams from home over the last several
weeks and they're you know pretty casual
I take questions from the audience and
we just look at breaking news issues and
whatever and during one of these it
appears as though i am spitting and
let's now start showing it to people and
there's it's hard to even watch but
there's a moment there where if it's not
clear what that is that or where it's
coming from but i am what my defense of
this and let it keep rolling while we're
talking here my defense is that this is
some kind of visual artifact that it's
not representative of what happened in
the room that day i think it's fake i
I'm messing it's fake I think that there
was a video glitch that explains what
we're seeing there and if you're
listening believe you're going to want
to check out the youtube clips for this
what do you make of that I think it's
you spitting you think so and
unfortunately whatever you were talking
about people aren't even paying
attention to at this point the weird
thing is the reason I think that this is
fake is that whatever it is appears to
be coming out of not my nose nor my
mouth but sort of like through my upper
lip and that's not where spit would come
from I disagree all right anyway I there
have been three liquid related scandals
here in the last couple of weeks there
was soup gate where I did an entire show
with borscht on my face which is an
Eastern European or historically Jewish
beet soup and Pat thought I had a cut or
pimple didn't tell me and I ended up
doing an entire show with borscht on my
face I could have saved the day there I
dropped the ball I think then we had
Kyra gate where it was revealed that Pat
admitted and I'm comfortable using the
term admitted Pat admitted that he uses
a Keurig to make coffee at home and then
now we have spit gate and I I believe
that this
when it's completely fake and fabricated
well how are you going to deal with this
controversy I mean I would recommend
giving an apology if you ended anyone
who will I apologize who would be
offended by that right or you can
manufacture another scandal and try to
distract the attention away from this as
you can see really high minded
conversations happening at david
pakman.com slash reddit